it's white sweet and can be added to a
cup of coffee or tea but unlike sugar
Stevia contains zero calories this
Factory in China's East produces about
400 tons of the natural sweetener every
year exporting it around the world
the stevia plant is originally from
Paraguay where it has been eaten for
over 100 years later it came to Japan
and was then introduced to China it's a
natural sweetener and ovaries many years
of consumption is being considered safe
this is just one of the companies
expected to benefit from the health
concerns surrounding artificial
sweeteners such as aspartame
Stevia production involves steeping
leaves in water removing unwanted plant
fibers and Distilling the essence down
to a fine powder
it can then be added to a range of foods
including drinks condiments and baked
goods China is the number one exporter
of stevia and other natural sweeteners
they're used all over the world but the
biggest Market is the Asia Pacific where
their popularity has risen with more
people becoming health conscious
sedentary Lifestyles and easy access to
cheap highly processed foods have seen
rates of diabetes and obesity in Asia
Skyrocket in recent years
this has led to the widespread use of
aspartame especially in carbonated
beverages but possible links to cancer
have seen some Brands discontinue use of
the artificial sweetener Trends toward
plant-based and organic eating have
increased interest in natural
alternatives but there are downsides in
some of the potential concerns might be
the health effects of intense sweeteners
and their impact on metabolic responses
the gut microbiome and appetite
regulation so excessive consumption of
any sweetener natural artificial
can contribute to increase craving for
sweetness and may still have an impact
on blood sugar levels dental health and
overall calorie intake
says Stevia remains an option for those
wanting to avoid sugar its market share
is so far small but he hopes growing
awareness and demand means Sweet Success
isn't far away Katrina Al Jazeera
jiangsu Province China